l'expérience et le poids des députés de
l'ouest canadien ont fait la différence
le caucus conservateur s'est donné une
chef par intérim
l'albertaine rona ambrose la première
fois c'était à organiser notre groupe
notre équipe nous avons une équipe très
forte
celle qui se présente comme bilingue
aura la mission de diriger l'opposition
officielle de commencer surtout la
reconstruction du parti
d'ici à ce que soit choisi un chef
permanent
on est vraiment en attente on n'est
vraiment pas pendant 84 ans au pouvoir
mais tous ne voient pas encore aussi
loin à peine deux semaines après la
défaite les questions demeurent
nombreuses
il faut refaire notre image de celui ci
cette première rencontre du caucus c'est
donc aussi l'occasion de comprendre la
mer des fêtes accompagné quelque chose
évitant certains déplorent le manque de
communication
d'autres l'absence du chef sur le
terrain qui peut cette rencontre encore
plus avec les écoles en privé stephen
harper à accepter ses responsabilités et
exhorté ses collègues à regarder vers
l'avenir
c'est sa première rencontre avec le
caucus depuis le 19 octobre un passage
que le chef sortant voulait discret
empruntant la porte de service
seuls ces quelques clichés croqués sur
le vif témoigne de son arrivée mais tout
bons leaders acceptent père quand ça va
bien mais accepte aussi quand ça va mal
stephen harper est reparti pour calgary
tout de suite après la rencontre
personne ne semble savoir exactement
quel rôle ils comptent jouer lors de la
prochaine session du parlement
et si daniel thibault radio canada
ottawa